So there are lots of different ways we could solve this.
Here's one: so we're going to define the procedure, is_friend.
First, we need to check if the name starts with a "D".
If it does, then our result is True, and we can return True right away.
If it's not, we're not done yet.
We need to check if the name starts with the letter, "N".
If it does, we return True.
If we got to here, it didn't start with either a "D" or an "N",
so that means we should return False.
Let's see how that works.
So we have 3 tests.
The first one starts with a "D", so it should be True.
The second one starts with an "N", should be True,
and the third one starts with an "F", so it should be False.
So there are lots of different ways we could have solved this.
We could have used an "else" here--so we could have had an "else",
and inside the "else" have the "if".
And if it's not, then we could have an "else" here and the return, False.
That will work, just the same--
a bit more code, but it also shows the structure
perhaps a little better than the first one.
The other thing we could do is return the result right away.
To do that, we need to introduce a new Python operator that we haven't used yet,
and that's the "or" operator.
So we could do just this.
This would be the equivalent of the long procedure we had before,
where checking if the name at position zero is equal to "D"
or the result of name at position zero is equal to "N".
That produces the same result.
And we've introduced the new construct, "or",
which gives us the logical "or" of the 2 operands on its left and right.